I don't know if many people have heard
about Abdullah Ocalan who is essentially
the thinker behind this revolution it
was his ideas that inspired and
motivated these people not only to
believe that they could transform their
own society but also you know once the
threat of Isis came that they could also
fight against Isis in the name of direct
democracy ecology and gender equality
and so the the foundations of this
movement and the reason why I emphasize
this is you know sometimes we forget
that you know some things some things
are not possible overnight when we're
trying to make change wherever we are in
the world and I can't imagine anyone
disagree in that you know obviously we
do we don't live in a perfect world so
there's many there's there's a long way
for us to go everywhere we are and so
these struggles and especially the
foundations of the Raja Revolution would
not have been possible the way it it
would not have been possible if there
weren't those foundations built so you
know up to La Jolla not only was he the
thinker behind there this this paradigm
but also spent 15 years in Syria talking
to the communities and the society every
day and trying to understand them so
that is potentially one of the biggest
differences between what's happening in
northern Syria right now are many other
revolutionary instances that in history
is that it's it's not a it's not a
vanguard as' movement or a revolution
that says okay we're here now and this
is the way we want you to live it's it's
built in a way that it's it's completely
embedded within its community and within
its society and therefore that's why the
most ground level of society the
communes are the where all the decisions
for society get made and so when I was
there in April I just want to speak a
little bit about like our trip and
kind of like go through the timeline
because each stop I feel like there's
there's anecdotes that really really
display the spirit of what's happening
there
so we arrived there the purpose of the
trip was mainly to do research and the
alternative education system of Roger
and the alternative economy so the
co-operative economy that is being put
into practice there and so we first
arrived to so you land in Iraq and you
cross over the border and the first
place you arrived in is what they call
the Jazeera accountant and so that's the
very that's the very east of I guess
like northern Syria so the north east
and so that was one of the first places
that this system was put into practice
and at the moment it's kind of like a de
facto capital and this is where a lot of
the women's assemblies exist the youth
assemblies and also where they have
something called the internationalist
commune of raw java which is where a lot
of internationalist go and and have the
opportunity to take part in six week or
six month education sessions which then
they can come back to you know go back
to their respective countries or
respective movements and you know
organized with that experience and so we
spent some time there and it was
remarkable how you know it's you know
it's the middle east it's that it's most
that where we were was mostly kurdish
people but also a lot of arab people
that we met as well and some of the
questions before i went that people
asked were you know the conflicts
between arabs and kurds you know because
unfortunately the region has been played
with sectarian conflicts for way too
long and i kind of expected to see that
a little bit myself and I kind of
questioned myself after when I realized
that that weren't the case as to why I
thought to expect that but you know I
realized for thousands of years these
people live together you
it more or less you know more or less
peacefully and yet nothing is ever a
fairy tale or or perfect but they were
able to figure out their problems
themselves and so I realized that when
when a system is built on the principles
of direct democracy ecology and gender
equality and inclusiveness like Laura
you know a pluralist society that that I
guess that collective that collective
memory comes back and comes back to
people quite easily and they figure out
how to live together you know in peace
and share with each other as well and I
realized that you know when we think
that certain sectarian conflicts and and
certain I guess like issues are
inevitable that it's something that we
probably need to question within
ourselves as to why we think that and so
that was I think the first step and what
I found quite quite shocking and what I
found quite shocking on the first stop
that I didn't expect to see so many
people getting along really for more
debates talks and interviews subscribe
today to the Institute of Arts and ideas
at AI TV
you